scientists urging drastic cuts to our
fossil fuel use say we're not on Pace to
avoid the worst impacts of climate
change as a result some of them now
support controversial technologies that
could blunt the Earth's Rising
temperatures broadly known as
geoengineering as senior National and
environmental correspondent Ben Tracy
reports the basic idea is to dim the Sun
I'm going to put this on hold it shut on
a recent morning along San Francisco Bay
two self-described Tech guys I mean
we're definitely not scientists launched
a small but provocative experiment it's
pathetic but it's a start Luke Iceman
and Andrew's song are the duo behind
make sunsets its mission is pretty clear
they sent a weather balloon filled with
small amounts of sulfur dioxide 12 miles
up into the stratosphere there we go
when the balloon pops the particles
released reflect sunlight theoretically
and microscopically cooling Earth should
a couple of tech Pros be the guys
experimenting with this with no
scientific background no this should
absolutely be something that is well
funded and done in responsible Labs with
adults and international consensus I'll
be thrilled to shut this company down in
the off chance that that happens in the
meantime we have to take action the work
of make sunsets is a stunt a provocation
Peter fromhoff is a climate scientist at
Harvard he says make sunsets has drawn
attention to geoengineering as a Central
response to Rising global temperatures
and runaway climate change I think of
Southern geoengineering as the worst
possible way to address climate change
that we need to take seriously what
exactly is solar geoengineering a set of
proposed Technologies to rapidly cool
the Earth by reflecting sunlight back
into space
the idea is based on the cooling effect
of volcanic eruptions when Mount
Pinatubo in the Philippines erupted in
1991 it spewed 20 million tons of sulfur
dioxide into the sky that reflected so
much sunlight global temperatures
dropped by an entire degree the
following year so one notion is that we
could mimic those volcanic eruptions by
sending specially equipped airplanes
into the stratosphere to do exactly the
same thing
the U.S government is now flying high
altitude planes to the stratosphere to
study what sunblocking gases may already
be there
Microsoft founder Bill Gates backed a
major project at Harvard using balloons
to deploy aerosols but tests were put on
hold after some pushback and while it
may seem far-fetched a recent United
Nations report seriously considers using
giant space mirrors to deflect sunlight
while other scientists propose mining
Moon dust and launching it at the Sun
at the Palo Alto Research Center in
Silicon Valley this white tent is a
makeshift lab for experiments with
something called Marine Cloud
brightening this will generate the plume
that will contain the aerosols it
injects salt water in the clouds over
the ocean the idea is you'll make the
clouds a little brighter and that will
reflect more sunlight back up into the
atmosphere exactly that's the idea those
effects could be beneficial or they
could be negative Kelly wanzer runs
Silver Linings in Organization
advocating for research Into Climate
interventions like Cloud brightening but
she says we need to quickly curb our
planet warming fossil fuel emissions
because dimming the sun isn't a
long-term solution it's a sign of
desperation this would not be the first
choice no or third or fourth choice you
have to compare it to overloading the
system with warming and this and the
environmental system starting to break
down which is where we're sitting on the
edge job this is something that might
provide some Cooling and bias some time
to rapidly shift away from fossil fuels
that's right but there are a lot of
things that we don't know how does the
climate system respond if you do that
over a long period of time
if it all sounds like science fiction
well it was 18 years of hitting the
Train the 2013 film snow piercer
depicted geoengineering gone awry
turning the planet into a dystopian snow
globe and confining Humanity to a
high-speed train
climate scientists are divided on
geoengineering in dueling public letters
one side calls for Accelerated research
while the other wants it banned wanting
the possible deployment of solar
geoengineering by individual nations
would be frightening and inequitable
solar gendering is unprecedented it will
impact everyone tsuchi talati is a
former energy Department official she
now runs an organization pushing for
developing nations to have a voice in
decisions about geoengineering many of
these countries have been
disproportionately impacted by climate
change I think right now the global
North is entirely dominating the
conversation and speaking on behalf of a
lot of different communities and
countries in the global South and I
think that's incredibly dangerous and
Incredibly disrespectful I think what we
really need is an international
conversation right solar geoengineering
is a desperate measure and one that we
should make every effort to avoid Peter
fromhoff says we also need to speed up
the clean energy transition so we don't
have to rely on risky and Rogue
experiments ready put it down here in an
attempt to supervise the Sun for CBS
Saturday morning I'm Ben Tracy in San
Francisco
it's fantastic I mean so much to think
about it snow piercer by the way really
good movie yeah you haven't seen it but
as he said it does sound like I mean
giant space mirrors shooting out Moon
dust it does sound like science fiction
but
we're there what does it say though that
we're there where we're talking about
these kinds of efforts and how desperate
and last-ditch efforts these are in
order to save our planet yeah a big
question mark also too who will
ultimately regulate all of this and how
are we going to come together and
figuring that part of it out